I think the next one should be called
the clover fields field the clover field
paradox so this is the third film in the
kind of connected not really maybe sort
of now film trilogy thing that is
Cloverfield I don't know what to call
this series so yeah this whole thing was
weird this was a movie that I've been
hearing about for I don't know about a
year or so and then it was supposed to
come out and then it got its release
date moved and then I got picked up by a
different studio and we were waiting for
a new release date and instead of
getting a new release date it just
appeared on Netflix and normally I'd say
that that's weird and smells of dumping
a junk movie except that it really kind
of fits with the weird roundabout way
these movies have been marketed to just
have it suddenly appear like him like a
viral video like just out of nowhere
boom here it is
you know the whatever marketing build up
there was was just you know the fact
that we knew what was coming didn't know
what it was and that's very Cloverfield
so before I get into this I suppose a
little bit of my own history with this
franchise
I remember the hype of that first
Cloverfield movie I actually got to see
it before it came out officially I can
manage to get into a preview screening
and it was the first film I ever saw to
make me physically ill because I don't
think I'm excessively prone to motion
sickness but yeah I had to leave the
theater and throw up in a trash can
because I couldn't make it to the
bathroom so that was my experience
trying to watch the original Cloverfield
10 Cloverfield Lane I didn't catch in
the theater but caught on home video and
loved last 10 minutes or so you know
excluded I think it it should have cut
off at a very specific point before it
sort of goes into its last beat but it
even would that intact it's still a good
movie and was
really would like to really tight really
tense and now we've got the Cloverfield
paradox so this to me is what will tip
it over into being a worthwhile trilogy
that had a weak start or a not
particularly good trilogy that somehow
managed to have a gold middle entry and
it's kind of leaning towards that second
one so I'm gonna I am
eventually going to talk spoilers in
this i'll start by not and just give
sort of my broad thoughts and broad
strokes with as few spoilers as I can
mention and given that honestly so
little is known about this movie I feel
like even talking about the premise as a
spoiler but I'm only gonna go as far as
say I don't know 10 15 minutes it's like
the main inciting incident alright if
you don't even want to know that maybe
you should just check out now and just
understand that I didn't think this was
that great I probably liked it more than
the first Cloverfield but that's many
just because it didn't make me sick
so that's a that's not a high bar to
clear in any case so we're dealing in a
probably near future I don't think they
actually say what year it takes place in
where there was a massive energy crisis
we don't have more details than that but
we don't need more details the earth is
running out of power and there are
experiments being conducted with a
particle accelerator in space in orbit
that I it's not really gone into detail
as to whether it needs to be in space to
work properly or exile or utilizing the
unique aspects of space to do something
that I couldn't do on another we don't
really know but somehow these
experiments are going to provide a new
source of energy for the planet before
basically before the lights go out and
everything descends into utter chaos
so they there's this crew up there
working on this thing that have been at
this for years like they've just been up
there trying to get this thing to work
and they're running out of tries to do
it because each time they fire it up to
see if it works they
burn a bit more of their resources and
they basically only got enough for a few
more goes on this thing well and then
they fire it up and it appears to work
and then as you would expect something
goes wrong so the the crew kind of gets
thrown about a little bit look out the
window and the earth is gone that's it
they just look out and just see a whole
lot of black a whole lot of stars as far
as setups go for what is a you know and
when I say setup as far as now we're
screwed
little things go going from a pretty
standard setup of experiment and space
goes wrong suddenly having the earth not
there that's a killer starting point it
really is I mean that's powerful
completely like holy cow what are the
options here you know did we move in
time did we move in space did the earth
move do you know what is it that happen
so many possibilities and that you know
captures uh the when this thing is that
it's best when you're looking at all the
possibilities of what it could be and
not knowing even how to begin narrowing
them down that's a lot of fun to work
with but as more the pieces fall into
place and exactly what's going on first
of all it ends up being something that
is really obvious because they blatantly
set it up really early on in a very
telegraphed manner that I think honestly
might be the moment that sinks the
entire film I'll have to wait till
spoilers to identify it by name but the
between that and I this thing needed to
have me engage with these characters I
had to care about the people who are up
on this station and while they weren't
bad they weren't like horror movie
fodder you know like uh just waiting for
them to die they weren't compelling they
weren't particularly good I mean to
compare to a movie that is thematically
similar and
has some similar you know of building
blocks the the movie sunshine by Danny
Boyle which is a very good movie falls
apart almost completely at the very end
but it is a really good movie and that
one worked I think just because we've
got to know these characters as people
and not just as plot functions or
exposition dumps and you know you get a
sense of their personalities beyond what
their function on the ship is and I
never really felt like I got to know too
many of these characters and the few
that I did get to know it's like boy
there's not a lot of depth to you is
there and that's that's kind of a shame
because if I could have connected with
these characters that it might have
worked because especially towards the
end there's one character in particular
that if they even hooked you into this
character you're just kind of just
watching to see where it goes you're not
invested you're not going love which if
the if the I suppose is the nominal lead
character of the whole piece did work
for you and did connect with you and
made you love the movie awesome I'm very
happy for you it didn't for me so I
think I need to start talking spoilers
so I can get into some of my more
specific Nick picks I think part of the
reason that I could not connect with
this main lead the character name I'm
not having a hard time I think it was
Ava I think the reason I couldn't
connect with her is because the first
few times we see her she's not a
character she is one half of the
exposition duo
and I mean that very literally the film
opens with her and her husband in this
car delivering really really badly
written expositional dialogue because
she's been asked to go up in help on
this project and she is reluctant to do
it wants to stay on earth with her
husband and you know he's trying to
convince her to go because he believes
it's important for her to take part in
this and he
he asked her why do they need you up
there and instead of giving an answer
like because they trust me because I'm
the best which still would have been
cheesy she goes basis she basically
launches into an explanation of the
situation now we'd already been getting
snippets of news bits and a couple of
actual contextual things that were
showing us powers running out there's an
energy crisis this thing gives hope but
she just sits there in this car and lays
out exactly all the exposition and then
it happens again later when she has a
communication call with her husband
basically after the time jumping forward
montage to establish that they've been
up there for a while
so I right off the bat I couldn't
connect with her because I'm like you're
not a character you're of you're an
exposition vehicle but then they try and
make her a character or later well I
take that back they don't try and make
her character they try and bank on the
idea that she is a character and you've
latched on to her and care about her but
I didn't because she didn't function as
a character for too long and eventually
she did start to function as a character
but by the time she did I there had been
basically no groundwork laid for me to
really care about her and I didn't
really care about any of the characters
particularly none of them really grabbed
me I mean Chris O'Dowd I liked so I was
kind of predisposed to him but I still
even he something seemed off to me I
don't know the whole thing was just
weird and okay the the single moment
that I think honestly might well just
kill the movie is the inclusion of the
clip of Donald Logue talking about how
what the what the particle accelerator
is doing could tear holes in dimensions
and there could be monsters and demons
he bases with with two words monsters
and dimensions
he basically spoiled the entire rest of
the movie like straight up
having just heard him suggest that the
instant things happen the instant the
thing was gone and as soon as I realized
this was not a case of they got flung
across the galaxy basically when they
found that other crew member in the wall
I I knew like Oh alternate dimensions
got it and that of course got my brain
also taking over oh okay this is what
caused the monsters and aliens OneNote
and whatnot in the other Cloverfield
movie because those are alternate
dimensions that have been damaged by the
use of this thing and the thing is I
figure that I figured this out pretty
much definitely by about a half hour
into the movie and then had to sit
through the rest of the movie which was
waiting to pay off those two things
that's like I yeah yeah I knew so the
final shot of a very large full-grown
Cloverfield monster I didn't care like
yeah yeah I figured that actually I'm
not I did care it irritated me because
you'd already blatantly laid it out with
Donald Logue you he didn't go so far as
to literally explain exactly what was
gonna happen but he laid out exactly how
we got here and he laid out something
that connects now all three films that
otherwise were unconnected but you had
to just show the monster because you had
to have that mm gut punch at the end
didn't you and that's just not having
any faith in your audience for us to
follow the fact that yeah I got that
already know let's literally stick one
in because we think it'll be punchy and
maybe people will cheer or something so
the the there seems to be a lack of
faith in the audience in terms of laying
this stuff out because I think overall
the movie would have worked a lot better
if things either had not been explained
at all to the degree that they were or I
think probably even the better option
would have been save the explanation
so for when the characters find out this
information and I don't just mean that
in terms of making a blade I mean like
don't drop obvious hints that the
characters are going to ignore and as
they work their way through trying to
figure out what's going on that was what
was really frustrating because the Donal
Logue thing I hope he was well paid for
his time what a waste but they're
watching this newscast in this
commentator and whatnot and so they see
him propose this notion and I'm not
saying that it should be somebody's
automatic response oh that guy on TV was
right but when something bizarre and
crazy happens and you have no idea how
it happened you'd think somebody would
have gone do you think that guy on the
TV was right but they don't which makes
them dumb it makes me as an audience
member well ahead of them which makes me
frustrated with them because they have
to catch up to me which makes me
disconnect from the film so things like
that and sticky Cloverfield monster at
the end to make it obvious for anyone
when the cheap seats way in the back who
maybe wasn't paying enough attention to
get it already I just think it could
have worked a lot better with a lot of
that stuff removed and a lot more stuff
implied especially in terms of the
interconnectedness of these things it
does another thing that I think is dumb
and actually it's funny that I mentioned
sunshine earlier because sunshine did
something similar which is that out of
nowhere we get a human villain and
that's dumb because the circumstances
are already so dire the stakes are so
high the situations so treacherous we
don't need a human villain I mean at all
the circumstances are the villain the
circumstances are all the are all the
complications and the issues and
problems they have to deal with there's
plenty of that we don't need a human
villain as well and boy that one's
doubly frustrating because the whole
thing with her they do something that I
hate which is they have a character that
and to be clear I buy her motivation for
what she does or tries to do at the end
but at the same time though I buy it on
paper I still hate it in execution
because it does what I hate that these
things tend to do which is to basically
have a character make a decision to do
something that is not a good thing for
reasons that maybe wouldn't cause me to
reach the same conclusion but makes
sense but then have them behave in the
same way that you would have a character
behave who is being evil because they
enjoy it like there's no sense of
conflict in her and what she's doing
they like she says I don't want to do
this I'm like you could have fooled me
because you are behaving in the manner
that a maniacal villain who's been
plotting this from the beginning would
be behaving and so yeah that that was
dumb when it started and then it was
dumber and execution and I'm realizing I
don't have a whole lot positive to say
about this it's not awful it really
isn't but it's just I don't know it's
just bland and it's an idea and a
concept that I would have liked but it's
just all down to the execution the
exposition is really clunky Lee handled
the performances are fine but not
particularly spectacular there's a lot
wrong in terms of the conclusion they
don't trust their audience enough to
actually roll with you know some of
these notions and ideas without being
told them bluntly which is actually
extra insulting because when you do an
idea this sci-fi like sci-fi people love
looking for the connections what a
sci-fi movie talks down to you the way
that this movie talks down to you it's
really kind of insulting I'm just
because the nature of the genre the
nature of this fandom they love picking
through the minutiae and looking at
every little thing and making the
connections and this film doesn't seem
to have any faith that they're gonna be
able to do that so all of that's
irritating and it also doesn't help that
like this look that just doesn't make
sense like they they say dimension
jumping or dimension merging or whatever
okay how does that have the wall-e
people how does that remove the guys arm
that now behaves completely into
didn't how does that get a colony of
worms stuffed inside another guy how no
explanation and it's to the point where
I I just feel like if you're going to
make a blatant explanation if you're
going to say this is why this is
happening but the explanation you gave
doesn't inherently make you oh now I
understand how all that stuff happened
then you should have done one of two
things you either should have explained
further for the instances that don't
make sense inherently with the premise
you gave or you need to not be as
blatant in the first place just have
them focus on getting home however they
can think to do it and don't worry about
explaining it just go with something
went wrong now everything screwed up
that they didn't find the balance
between how engaging their unanswered
questions were and how much of an answer
they should actually give and I think
they either needed to be more exhaustive
or actually my preference would adjust
to be don't explain nearly as much as
you do because I think it would have
been better and there's a lot on paper
that I feel like could have worked about
this I feel like making it a Cloverfield
movie because I'm pretty sure it wasn't
originally which is the same thing that
happened to tank Cloverfield Lane and I
feel like the stuff inserted upon it to
make it fit the Cloverfield brand was
most of what was dragging it down in the
end so now that we've actually had a
film that offers an explanation to
explain why the things that happened in
the other clover fields happen and gives
a vague way that they're interconnected
can we stop so the Cloverfield paradox I
keep wanting to call the guard pot of
the god particle cuz that was the
working title for so long but in any
case did you see it what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it I don't know if I'm gonna
tick off this particular fandom I don't
know if Cloverfield has rabid fans or
not it has a very speculative banking
community but I don't know if there is
defensive as Marvel fans or DC fans or
Star Wars fans or and if the other fans
way
a tendency to tick off I'm sure I'll
find out in any case whatever your
thoughts are drop swimming down in the
comments let's talk about it do all that
stuff check me out on patreon and follow
me on Twitter or listen to my podcast
links for all this stuff is down in the
description and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]